hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John old
Humphrey so we're all ready to watch the
spider-man far from home trailer it's
coming it's coming eventually but
instead we got this right burden Sony
Pictures thanks guys hope Brazil is
having a good time with you off this is
James Gunn's I don't know produced or
something maybe he wrote it he touched
it yeah he gave an input on it and we
weren't sure if we're gonna cover it but
one of our top reward tiers over at our
patreon every video you request we must
definitely do and put up on the youtubes
and today comes from Jason Dolan he's a
great friend of mine and he also is one
of our top patrons I wish all my friends
were like you Jason Dunn pledge the
Patriot right away increase it you'll
get it back yeah I'm gonna go above and
beyond I want that so he really said
that we should check this out he knows
people who worked on it so that means
we're gonna crap all over this trailer
yeah you brought this on yourself Jason
especially your operators left I hope
you're friends with Dolan and I hope
your friends are done they messed that
joke this is Ben bass she had that
touching herself with a massager for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
skooch signs
it's the Kent farm is reduce it this
feels like a NOLA trailer oh this is
totally playing on it specifically right
it has to go to be dude this is like the
Man of Steel straighter like the logos
never yeah it's gonna have some dark
twist huh
oh this is a bold move by Sony taking a
jab at Superman kinda moving here
[Music]
I love this
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna be Henry Cavill in the black
suit yeah I love what they're doing here
it is written by a couple of guns is
that what I mark gun and Brian gun come
on so many guns it's so many guns oh man
that was that was fascinating this
really is like you know what if he's
just bloodthirsty I like it because they
even have the logos looking like the
nolan ones yeah very triumphant building
music I love it I don't know if it's
just because I think the I think the 30
second thing or the trailer for trailer
thing gave away like oh this is gonna be
something really dark in the first half
I thought I did a really good job at
going oh it's a Man of Steel ripoff dark
about to happen right really darker but
it really is like young evil Superman Oh
totally which is like the perfect little
up I love a twist on something that's
like really simple but very effective
yeah surprise like good a movie like
this has it and I'm sure other people
have attempted it but on this scale you
know that somebody else hasn't come up
with this already because it's the
perfect idea for the superhero landscape
now because yeah and especially the way
they designed this trailer to play on
all of those things that kind of every
superhero movie does especially with the
youthful hero or it's like you're
special yeah different
you are a gift sets of all the things
that you're gonna be sort of
extrapolating to mind only to reverse
them and it's it really is though like
cuz this is Martha and Jonathan Kent you
have it something crash-lands we
wouldn't have a baby it's exactly the
Superman story a really messed up
twisted that he's an evil thing but he
has like Superman powers he flies he's
got super strength looked like he had a
laser thing with the door yeah pretty
surprised this is like a bold move I
think I know Sony has their spider-verse
that's Marvel adjacent it's down the
street and James Gunn is you know he's
doing his thing with Suicide Squad to
apparently to do something that's
directly like a spin on a classic DC
story they're just not calling it
Superman yeah no some like comic book
this is based off of that I'm just not
aware about or something like that like
I have no idea
at least from visually standpoint you
look it looks like you're watching the
Man of Steel trailer oh yeah totally
Plus this made me think you know earlier
in the year we had Emily Blunt and John
Krasinski and now we have Elizabeth
Banks and the other guy who was in love
with Pam you know in rural America
somewhere Roy from the office yeah yeah
so you know he's probably gonna turn in
a very like surprisingly gripping
dramatic Mormon stuff and they got the
creepiest looking kid to they're always
good in Hollywood at finding creepy
children yeah and then you know the next
role he gets he's gonna be super sweet
or something this is how you do the dark
DC reboot of Superman making interesting
so make him a hero it's making
interesting movie I don't know I love it
I did I I really wasn't sure what we
were about to watch I have never heard
of this movie until Jason Dolan asked us
to check it out yeah very very intrigued
very excited what is James Gunn's
involvement producing oh this says right
there is it like in the trailer produced
by James no his like idea then cuz like
well I mean no I mean it's pretty
obvious that is whoever is siblings or
family members are the guns that rotate
his family been written and written by
Mark and
gun families like the way no I knew
there were two other brothers and maybe
one of them is one of these guys but
they're like four or five guns at least
so many guns its arsenal hope YouTube is
not hearing the word guns and thinking
we're talking about art like we need
weaponry who makes sure to pronounce the
ends extra oh man I I was really taken
aback by this I'm looking forward to
this movie hey Jason thank you so much
for requesting this bud this is an
awesome ass trailer you got cool friends
who make cool stuff man
and you know makes cool stuff is Jason
Dolan as well last time he was out here
we had dinner together and he's working
on something pretty special and when you
have a comic-con panel buddy I hope we
get a host that oh yeah because wood
everything got gearing up you're
destined to have a comic-con panel for
that specific project you are working on
and I read the first one of the early
drafts of what he's working on he's a
writer and it was pretty awesome that
was pretty awesome stuff and Jason's
just an overall very nice guy very nice
guy he's always he's one of those dudes
is always out trying to help you know
and people like that perform great
relationships and are in this business
long term because he works on himself he
does his own thing but he's also
constantly trying to connect people and
he's also trying to help at whatever
area he can he's very like very kind of
almost any circle we'd like it been
invited to her he's for people know of
him he's like a big talk you know just
because of the kind of person he is so
I'm really grateful to know you dude you
got a high reputation don't ever lose it
buddy man yeah here doing the Lord's
work yes bring the people together right
and cool ass movies guys what do you
think of this bright burned trailer are
you excited for it is this a sequel to
bright yeah you guys can subscribe to
reject nation click that notification
bell check us out patreon we got weekly
Q&A a TV show reaction watch longs for
many of shows that includes attack on
Titan my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood Riverdale Gotham
and supernatural and John also does
plenty of music video coverage much love
to all of you this is this is
as a fracas where's the day we watched
your trailer words like I'm pleasantly
surprised can't wait to see that yeah I
hope this is good thank you guys